[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى نبدا من باريس في يوم اخر من
الاحتقار مواجهات بين قوى الامن ومحتاجين
اكراد على مقتل افراد من جاليتهم من قبل
رجل تحوم الشكوك وحول ارتباطه بافكار اقصى
ومن بيت لحم في الضفه الغربيه ننقل لكم
الاستعدادات للاحتفال بعيد الميلاد في
كنيسه المهد وفقا للتقويم الغربي الذي
تتبعه بعض الطوائف المسيحيه الفلسطينيه
في فرنسا مواجهات بين الشرطه ومقتدين في
باريس مصادر رسميه تقول ان المهاجمه اعترف
بدوافعه العنصريه وانتقادات وتساؤلات
لماذا لم تعتبر السلطات الهجوم عملا
ارهابيا
اوكرانيا تعلن مقتل 10 اشخاص واصابه عشرات
في قصف روسي كثيرصون وزير دفاعا يقول ان
بلاده قادره على منع مثل هذه العمليات اذا
حصلت على اسلحه نوويه واشنطن تصف الهجوم
بالوحشيه والموالون لروسيا يتهمون القوات
الاوكرانيه بقصف احياء سكنيه في دميات
اوروبا في مواجهه شبح الاضرابات عشرات
الالاف من عمال السكك الحديديه يخوضون
اضرابا في بريطانيا ولندن تستعين بالجيش
لتعويض موظفي المطارات وفي فرنسا حوالي
نصف رحلات القطارات السريعه تلغى بسبب
اضراب عمال السكك الحديديه
عواصف ثلجيه تؤدي بحياه 19 شخصا وتحرم
الملايين من الكهرباء في الولايات المتحده
وشركات الطيران تلغي الاف الرحلات الجويه
جراء احوال الطقس في فتره عيد الميلاد
وفي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد ناقشنا على
منصاتنا الرقميه سياقه المواجهات بين قوى
الامن ومحتجين من الجاريه الهرديه على
مقتل افراد من جاليتهم في استهداف للمركز
الثقافي في باريس وفي الوقت الذي قال فيه
منظم والمظاهره ان المواجهات مع قوى الامن
لا تمثلهم افادت مصادر قضائيه الفرنسيه
بان منفذ الهجوم اعترف اثناء التحقيق بان
دوافعه عنصريه
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال الثالث في رايكم لماذا لم
السلطات الفرنسيه الهجوم العنصريه
بالارهابي وقد جاءت النتيجه على النحو
التالي 13% ارجع الامر الى محددات قانونيه
بينما قال
87% انه يعود لاعتبارات سياسيه هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم
دخوله صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد عامين من قيود انفردتها جائته كرونه
احتفالات واسعه في مناطق مختلفه باعياد
الميلاد وفق التقويم الغربي
[موسيقى]
طلب منظمه مظاهرات باريس من المتظاهرين
طلبوا منهم من المتظاهرين في ساحه
الجمهوريه
مع الامن الفرنسي لا تمثلهم الدعوه جاءت
بعد مواجهات بين الشرطه ومحتاجين من
الجاليه الكرديه على مقتل 30 من الاكراد
في الهجوم الذي استهدف المركز الثقافيه
الكردي وسط العاصمه باريس امس واكد
المتظاهرون ان الهجوم ارهابي وان دوافعه
سياسيه وشارك في المظاهره عدد من
السياسيين والبرلمانيين الفرنسيين خصوصا
من اليسار الفرنسي من جهته قال قائد شرطه
باريس 31
اصيب جراء مواجهات اليوم
وقالت الشرطه الفرنسيه انها اعتقلت 11
شخصا خلال الاشتباكات التي اندلعت بين
قوات الامن ومتظاهرين ومحتاجين على الهجوم
الذي اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص من الجاليه
الكرديه يوم امس الجمعه وقد رفعت النيابه
العامه قرار احتجاز المشتبه به لاسباب
صحيه
وجاءت هذه الاحداث في اعقاب مظاهره نظمتها
الجاليه الكرديه ومتضامنين معها في ساحه
الجمهوريه وسط العاصمه باريس سانديدا
بالهجوم الدامي قبل ان تتحول الى اشتباكات
بين جموع من المشاركين في التظاهره وقوات
الامن وقد تسببت المواجهات في تحطيم عدد
من السيارات وادرام النيران في حاويات
النفايات بينما تعرضت بعض واجهات المحل
للكسر
كان المشتبه به في تنفيذ هجوم باريس والذي
عرفته وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه عرفته
بويليام ام قد اكد انه ارتكب الاعتداء
لدوافع عنصريه وفقما كشفته بل كشفه مصدر
مقرب من التحقيقات وقال المصدر ان الشرطه
تعثرت بحوزه المشتبه به على حقيبه صغيره
تضم مخزنين او ثلاثه ممتلئه بطلقات الرصاص
وعلبه طلقات من عيار 45 بداخلها 25 طلقه
على الاقل
من جانبه قال المجلس الديمقراطي الكردي له
من غير المقبول عدم وصف الهجوم بالارهابي
مرجحا وجود دوافع سياسيه
وقد نشرت وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه صورا
التقطت من كاميرات مراقبه تظهر لحظه دخول
المنافذ صالون حلاقه واطلاقه النار داخل
المكان ما ادى الى مقتل شخص وجرح اخرين في
حين قتل المهاجم اثنين اخرين في مكان قريب
وقال وزير العدل الفرنسيه
في حداد في عقاب الهجوم الذي استهدف
الدائره العاشره في باريس واسفره عن مقتل
ثلاثه اشخاص من الجاليه الكرديه وقال
مرتين في تصريحات صحفيه انه حرص على لقاء
ممثلينا عن الجاليه الكرديه لياكد لهم
الدعم الكامل ورده على الجدل مشان توصيف
الجريمه بانها ارهابيه قال هناك فرقا بين
الجريمه العنصريه والجريمه الارهابيه
يتمثلوا في شرط الانتماء الى ايديولوجيه
سياسيه يتم تبنيها حسب حتى تصنف الجريمه
بانها ارهابيه حسب تعبير
وبحسب معلومات نشرتها وسائل الاعلام
الفرنسيه نقلا عن مصادر في الشرطه فان
منفذ الهجوم فرنسي يبلغ من العمر 69 عاما
وهو سائق قطار متقاعد سبق ان اذن ارتكاب
اعمال عنف باستخدام السلاح كما انه متهم
بتنفيذ هجوم عنصري وتخريب ممتلكات الثامن
من ديسمبر 2021 بحسب مصادر في الشرطه
المتهم طعن مهاجرين اثنين على الاقل بسلاح
ابيض في مخيم في باريس والحق اضرار بعدد
من الخيام
لاحقا اودع المتهم الاودي على الحبس
الاحتياطيه لكن القضاء اضطر الى اطلاق
سراحه تنفيذا لاحكام القانون في الثانيه
عشر من ديسمبر الجاري ووضعه تحت المراقبه
القضائيه بعد مرور عام على توقيفه سبق ان
حكم عليه عام 2017 بالسجن لمده سته اشهر
مع وقف التنفيذ الاحتيازته اسلحه ناريه
خلال خلافا للقانون وكان حينها يتردد على
ميدان للرمايه
من باريس ينضم الينا الدكتور مانيوال رئيس
معهد الاستشراف والامن في اوروبا ومن
باريس ايضا الدكتور بشير نفسي مدير مرصد
الدبلوماسيه والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في
باريس اهلا وسهلا بكم ما ابدا بك دكتور
منور
الذي ارتكب هذه الجريمه له ثواب قبل قيل
انه يعني اخرج عنه منذ 11 يوما فقط كيف
يمكن لشخص اخرج عنه منذ 11 يوما ان يرتكب
جريمه من هذا النوع لا يحضر يخضع
للمراقبه على سبيل المثال
الاصيل
ببساطه بانه اكمل سنه من الحجز الاحتياطي
النظره لجريمه التي قام بها وليد جريمه
عنصريه لا تتطلب سجنه الفتره اطول تضع فقط
مراقبه عليه وهو كان فعلت الرقابه
القضائيه منذ الثانيه عشر من شهر ديسمبر
وكما قلتم هذا الشخص لديه حالات سابقه
محاولات محاولات
هجوم على مجموعه مسلمه وهذه جريمه
صفاتين
2016 ثم
مره اخرى همم
هجم عليهم وبالتالي فالسؤال تترحم
الى سؤال اكثر اهميه هو هل هذا الوسائل
اللازمه للسيطره الاشخاص الذين يعتبرون
ظنا انهم خطرون ويحتمل يقوم بشيء فهو يطلق
سراحه في الثانيه عشر من شهر وبعد سنه من
الاعتقاد وبالتالي السلطه لا استطيع ان
تعرف انه سيقوم بذلك الشيء اليوم صحيح
ولكن هناك اتهامات للسلطه بانها لم تحمي
الاكراد لذلك اسالك يعني هل كان يجب
مراقبته بشكل افضل على سبيل المثال
لا لا بوليس نظافه
الافضل
حتى يتم حل هذه المشكله اذهب الى اليك
دكتور
قريب بمعنى هل الاكراد الذين اتهموا
السلطه بانها لم تحملهم بما يكفي يحقون في
هذا الاتهام وماذا كان يمكن للسلطه ان
تفعل
طبعا هو القول انهم حطين من عدمه هي مساله
انطباعيه شامله باعتبار ان الاجابه البديه
والواضحه ان وقعت محاكمه هذا الشخص عندما
قام بذنب في الاطار القوانين ما تسمح به
القوانين الفرنسيه وحاله الاحتفاظ في كل
الاحوال في قوانيزيه لا تتجاوز الثناء
طبعا ان استشعر او ان يشعر الاكراد بانه
مستهدفون في هذا طبيعي واعتيادي على
اعتبار ان لهم سابقه منذ حوالي 10 سنوات
فهذا الشعور المتنامي ان الاكراد بالذات
في المستهدفون همم قد يجد له ارضيه همم
معقوليه نوع الماء في همم العمليه
الانطباعيه العامه ما يعيش هو الاكلات
خاصه ولكن في حقيقه الامر الامر في تقديره
يتجاوز حدود الاكراد لنطرح مساله همم
جوهريه هي يعني مساله الاعتداء على
المهاجرين بصفه عامه همم وبالتالي مساله
تكييف الي حصل اليوم تكيف المساله
الاعتبارها مساله عنصريه يطرح الابواب او
الاسئله الكبيره حول هذا الموضوع طبعا
الفوارق او الفواصل بينما هو او تصنيف ما
هو عنصر وتصنيف ما هو ارهابي هي قد تكون
مفاصل همم جزئيه على اعتبار ان ولكن على
كل حال الذهاب في هذا المنحه يدل على ان
المساله حدود الاكراد مع الاحترام
والاكلات الاعتبار همم دكتور هذا هو سؤال
همم لاقول يطرحه الجميع ولكن يطرح بكثره
في هذا التوقيت اطرحه على الدكتور ايمان
هل يجب ان يصنفه هجوم كهذا على انه ارهابي
وليس عنصري
فقط كما يتم ال ال المصارعه
لوصف اي هجوم يرتكبه شخص مسلم على سبيل
المثال بانه هجوم ارهابي
بشكل بشكل
فعلا تقريبا مستحيل ان يعرف ان سيقوم
بالهجوم مره اخرى همم على من سيهجم لقد
هاجم الجاليه الكرديه ولا يمكن يعرف انهم
اكراد فقط كان يعرف انهم اجانب كما فعل
قبل بضعه اسابيع بالهجوم على معسكر
اللاجئين هذا نعم هذا ارهاب ولكن ارهاب
وبالتالي هل يجب ان يوصف بانه هجوم ارهابي
لان هذا مكمان الانتقاد الان كثيرون يطالب
بان يوصف بانه ارهابي كما كما توصف اعمال
اخرى يقوم بها او عرب ومسلم
مره اخرى اقول التحقيق ما زال جاريا
ولسه هناك ارتباط او انتماء لديه فهذا
الشخص لن يكون مذكور اسمه ضمه الاشخاص
الذي تحت المراقبه
وهناك انواع اعداد كبيره منهم
الارهابين
حاليا الاتحاد
الدكتور
بشير دكتور بشير ما رايك ان كيف يمكن
الاجابه على هذا السؤال
يعني الاجابه طبعا التكيف القانوني وهنا
المطلق من القانون نذهب الى السياسي مرورا
بالايديولوجي التكيف القانوني ان الفارقه
بين ما هو عنصري ليصبح عمليا وقانونيا ااه
يعني هو عمل ارهابي يجب او يشترطوا فلنقل
نقطه الانتماء الفكري او الانتماء اللجوجي
حاليا في هذا التطور من التحقيقات لم يقع
الى هذه اللحظه وهنا اتكلم بالجانب
القانوني المجرد اثبات ان هذا الشخص ينتمي
الى مجموعه متطرفه رغم ان كل توجهاته
الفكريه وكل ما تقريبا ما طرحه الذهاب الى
العنف همم الاقصى كما نسميه يدخل في خانه
همم المنظمات متواجده ولكن متواجده كذلك
في فرنسا ورقم ان الدوله يعني تقوم
بمجهودات من اجل محاصرتها من خلال يعني
تجميد الجمعيات مثلا هنا اذكر جمعيه فرنسا
الهويه وهي من الجمعيات التي حدثت على
العنف والتي اا يعني اتخذت في حقها الدوله
الفرنسيه همم اجراءات ولكن صراحه مساله
هذا التكييف فل نقول في هذه المرحله مهمه
مهمه جدا لماذا لانه تقريبا عندما نتبعه
هنا سادخل وتكلم قليلا في الجانب السياسي
عندما نرى مختلف السياسيه
[موسيقى]
الاكثر والاستدراج كنا نود ذلك بالفعل
ولكن ليس هناك وقت شكرا لك من باريس
الدكتور بشير النفسي مدير مرصد
الدبلوماسيه والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في
باريس وكان معنا من باريس عندنا الدكتور
الرومانيويل اسمع عادل استشراف والامن في
اوروبا شكرا جزيلا لكم معا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه مقتل
عشره اشخاص وجرحى 55 اخرين في تجدد القذف
الروسي على احياء عده في مدينه خيرسون
وقال وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيين القصف الذي
وصفه بالوحشيه ليس جريمه حرب جديده بل انه
انتقام من سكان المدينه لمقاومتهم
الاحتلال واضاف ان اوكرانيا
على حصولها على صواريخ ومدفعيه بعيده
المدى من جهتها وصفت بروجيت برينكا
السفيره الامريكيه في اوكرانيا الهجوم
الروسيه على خيرسون
عشره اشهر وتتوالا فصول حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا باللغه كانها تزداد دراوته يوما
بعد اخر
تصدر القصف الروسي وعلى مدينه خرسن جنوب
اوكرانيا اخر الانباء وذكر انه اسفر عن
سقوط 10
القوات الروسيه باستهداف المنطقه عشرات
المرات بالمدفعيه والراجمات الصواريخ
والدبابات قائلا ان القذائف الروسيه ضربت
ايضا منشات البنيه التحتيه ورياض الاطفال
والمدارس والمستشفيات والمتاجر والمصانع
والمباني السكنيه
الرئيس الاوكراني
قال انما يجري ليس حربا وانما هو ارهاب
وقتل بهدف التخويف والتلذذ على حد قوله
وما فتيات خير سنه تعرض لقصف الروسي
تتوالى فصوله منذ ان استعادتها اوكرانيا
وتطلب كيس من الغرب منذ اسابيع مزيدا من
المساعدات الماليه والعسكريه خلص ليست
الوحيده في قلب المعارك قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان سلاح الجو اسقط مقاتله
اوكرانيه وثلاث مرايات وعشرات الطائرات
المسيره في دوناتس وعند القوات الاوكرانيه
صدت عددا من الهجمات الروسيه على مناطق
مختلفه في المقاطعتين وانه محاولات الجيش
الروسي لاقتحام مدينه باخمود باعت بالفشل
رغم كثافه بقصيها وتقول اوكرانيا ايضا ان
قواتها قتلت عشرات الجنود الروس ودمرت
منظومتين مدفعيه خلال قصفها مواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه في مقاطعه الزبرجيا وان
المقاتلات الاوكرانيه تنفذ غارات مستمره
على تلك المواقع والمنظمات الصاروخيه
والطائرات المسيره في هذه الاثناء يدور
الحديث في كييف من جديد عن ان شان روسيا
هجوما على اوكرانيا انطلاقا من اراضي
بالروسيه ليس مستبعدا لكن موسكو تنفي ان
يكون التحالف العسكري بين روسيا وبيلا
روسيا مرتبطا بالحرب في اوكرانيا وتقول ان
مهمته تتمثل في صد اي عدوان محتمل ضد
اراضي بيلاروسيا حليفتها
معنى من عمان اللواء فايز الدولي الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء 11
شهرا على هذه الحرب في اي اطار تندرج عوده
خيرسون الى الواجه
يعني اولا عوده خرسا هي لم تخرج يعني تم
استعاده السيطره على الاجزاء التي تقع الى
الشمال من ارض نيبر
كان التوقع ان تقوم القوات الروسيه بعبور
النهر ولكن يبدو ان هناك معضلات عده بناء
الخطه الدفوع المنظومه الدفاعيه الروسيه
وصعوبه التنفيذ عمليهور يضاف الى ذلك
تركيز الهجمات
الروسيه في اقليم جمباز همم في دونيسك
واستعداد القتال تحديدا حول باخمود فتم
اعاده صياغه الاولويات وبالتالي تم نقل
جزء من القوات التي كانت مخصصه لخوض معركه
قرش تم نقلها قسم الى زمولوجيا وقسم اخر
لتعزيز القوات المقاتله في دونيسك وبعض
المناطق الاخرى اذن يقول خرسون لا تزال
داخل برواز الصوره القتاليه ولم تخرج لم
تخرج الحديث ايضا
اولا يعني ودا اسالك ما حاجه روسيا الى ان
تكون الاراضي البيلاروسيه جزءا من هذه
الحرب
يعني هذا في البدايه كان من اجل تشتيت
الجهد
وافشال الخطه الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه لكن بعد
الفشل الذي حدث في كييف واجبرت القوات
الروسيه على الانتفاء والانسحاب والاكتفاء
بمحاوله السيطره على الاقاليم الاربعه
التي تقع على الشرق والجنوب من نهر همم لم
يعد هناك حديث في الفتره الاخيره همم تم
همم كثره الحديث وتناولت الاخبار ولكن
هناك او همم مؤشرات يعني الجانب الروسيه
في الجانب الاوكراني همم يؤكد ولكن يقلل
من الاحتماليه انما المؤشرات التي يمكن
اعتمادها تبقى هذا الخيار ضمن دائره
المنطقه الرمادي ما هي المعوقات المعوقات
استدعاء استنادا الى وكالات الاستخباراتيه
الغربيه سواء لا الشيعه اي اي او وزاره
الدفاع البريطاني كلاهما اشار الى تراجع
حده القتال بسبب نقص الذخائر والصواريخ
وبالتالي عدم قدره الجيش الروسي على شن
عمليات ودخول فصل الشتاء اما ما هي
المؤشرات الداعمه يتم الارتكاز والاجتناد
الى خطاب الرئيس بوتين في غرفه العمليات
او في قياده عمليات همم
المسؤول عن اداره عمليات المنطقه الخاصه
اول هذه المؤشرات استخدام الرئيس بوتن
كلمه حرب بدل من عمليه عسكريه خاصه همم
الاخرى انه اكد على زياده عدد الجيش
الروسي الى واحد ونص مليون اكد على ضروره
دمج الطائرات المسيره والذكاء الاصطناعي
في اداره المعركه اكد على ضرو رفع سويا
الثالوث الاستراتيجي وقام بتزويد الوحدات
المعنيه بصواريخ تسيركن والسرمد اكد على
ضروره زياده فاعليه المنظومه الاداريه
مجمل هذه العوامل وغيرها يوحي بان روسيا
قد تشن عمليه ولكن السؤال متى هل في فصل
الشتاء كما حدث في المره الماضيه ام تنتظر
حتى بدايه الربيع انما من من اللحظه التي
يتحدث بها حتى ذلك الوقت سيكون هناك
متغيرات تنفي او تؤكد شكرا جزيلا لك يا
سياده اللواء فايز الدويري متحدثا الينا
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا يتوقف الليل عشرات الالاف من
عمال السكك الحديديه في عموم المملكه
المتحده عن العمل في اضراب للمطالبه
بتحسين ظروف العمل وزياده الاجور وقد شملت
الاضرابات قطاعات النعماليه اخرى فيما
استعانه السلطات البريطانيه بقوه من الجيش
القيامي بعمل موظفي الجوازات في ثمانيه
مطارات اضافه الى قطاعات اخرى وفي فرنسا
ينفذ سائقون ومراقبون وعمال في السكه
الحديديه الفرنسيه اضرابا عن العمل
للمطالبه بتحسين اوضاعهم ورفع اجورهم وقال
شركه السكك الحديديه الفرنسيه ان 200,000
مسافر تاثروا بسبب الاضراب عقبه الغاء
رحلات قطرين
السرعه من اصل خمسه قطرات
في وقت حرج تتزامن اضرابات عماليه في كل
من بريطانيا وفرنسا على خلفيه مطالبات
تتعلق بزياده الاجور وتحسين ظروف العمل
استهدفت نقابات عماليه عطله عيد الميلاد
باضرابات متلاحقه من ليله الاحد سيتوقف
عشرات الالاف من عمال السكك الحديديه في
عموم المملكه المتحده عن العمل ويقول
المضربون ان نصف خطوط السكك الحديديه
ستغلق كما ان القطارات في معظم اسكتلندا
وويلز ستتوقف قالت صحيفه الجارديان ان
اكثر من 16 مليون شخص يسافرون برا عشيه
عيد الميلاد ونقلت الصحيفه توقعات شركه
تحليل بيانات النقل ان تكون اوقات الرحلات
البريه اطول بنحو 14% مقارنه بالفتره
نفسها من العام الماضي لن ينخرط عمال
السكك الحديديه البريطانيون وحدهم في
الاضرابات المجدوله سلفا بل ستنضم اليهم
نقابه عمال الاتصالات التي تشمل عمال بريد
ونقابه التمريض وموظفوا الجوازات في
ثمانيه مطارات السلطات البريطانيه استعانت
بقوات من الجيش لتعويض اضراب موظفي العديد
من المرافق المحتجه كالاسعاف والجوازات
رئيس الحكومه ريش سوناك اعرب عن استيائه
مما وصفها بالفوضى الناجمه عن تلك
الاضرابات مؤكدا فتح باب الحوار مع منظمها
في فرنسا وبحسب شركه السكك الحديديه
الوطنيه
1000 مسافر من اضراب ينفذه سائقون
ومراقبنا وعمال في السكك الحديديه ادى الى
الغاء اربعين بالمئه من الرحلات القطارات
فائقه السرعه شكوى المطربين الفرنسيين هي
هي تحسين الاوضاع ورفع الاجور وتخوض
الحكومه معهم مفاوضات لالغاء اضرابات
مرتقبه لدى عوده الفرنسيين من العطله
فرنسي حول ما يوصف بالاحتكار النقابي
لتنظيم الاضرابات على مواقع انخراط
مجموعات غير نقابيه في الدع للاحتجاج
والاضراب وهو ما قد يعني خروج الامر نسبيا
من يد الكيانات النقابيه ويلقي بالتالي
ظلالا على مصير اي مفاوضات بينها وبين
الحكومه
تحتفل الطوائف المسيحيه التي تتبع التقويم
الغربي في الاراضي الفلسطينيه اليوم بعيد
الميلاد المجيد وتحمل احتفالات هذا العام
شعار روح الميلاد تجمعنا حيث تتركز
فعاليات الاحتفال في مدينه بيت لحم بساحه
كنيسه المهد والشوارع المحيطه بها واستقبل
المحتافلون موكب البطريار كبير باتيستا
بيتزا القادم من مدينه القدس المحتله عبر
احدى بوابات الجدار الفاصل ليقيم قداس
منتصف الليل
[موسيقى]
ومعنى من ساحه كنيسه المهد في بيت لحم
مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو شماله سمير
صف لنا الاجواء
يعني الاجواء هي اجواء احتفاليه منذ صباحي
هذا اليوم في جميع شوارع وازقه وكنيسه
المهد وفي باحثه كنيسه البهدله التي يحتفل
من خلالها الفلسطينيون وتحديدا الطوائف
المسيحيه التي تسير وقع تقويم الغربي بعيد
الميلاد المجيد ربما الصوره تثبت من تتحدث
عنه وهناك الجموع ما زالت متواجده رغم
قساوه الطقس وبروده الجو هناك ما زال
الفلسطينيون وايضا الحجيج من دول العالم
الذين وصلوا الى فلسطين والى الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وتحديدا الى بيت لحم ما زالوا
تواجدون في هذا المكان الذي تتزين في وسطه
وسطه
شجره الميلاد باضاعتها وزيرتها وايضا هو
بعد ساعه من الان تقريبا ستبدا مراسم
الرسميه الدينيه المتعلقه بقداس منتصف
الليل الذي يتراسه غضبه غبطه البطريرك
بيير باتيستا بتسابالا وذلك بحضور رسمي من
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس وايضا لفيف
من الشخصيات الوطنيه وسياسيه والمجتماعيه
وايضا رجال الدين الذين سيحضرون قداس
منتصف الليل في داخل كنيسه المهد- خارجها
هناك التجمعات من العائلات وايضا الزائرين
والحجيج والمواطنين من الاراضي الفلسطينيه
الذين قدموا واستطاعوا من القدوم الى هذا
المكان للاحتفال في هذا العيد في هذه
المناسبه التي يعتز بها الفلسطينيين رغم
مراقصات الاحتلال التي دائما هي تحاول
تنقيص الحياه على الفلسطينيين في مرافق
حياتهم بشكل بشكل عام ال غبطه البطريرك
اليوم عاش هذه التجربه من خلال
اجتيازه للجدار الفاصل الذي يشتم او يقتطع
من اراضي المحافظه تقريبا 3% من اراضي
الفلسطينيين وبالتالي هذه التجربه التي
عاشها غبطه البطريرك عندما قدم من مدينه
القدس الى بيت لحم تحت انظار جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هناك
مناقصات ما زالت مستمره على حياه
الفلسطينيين وايضا على رجالات الدين وفي
هذه الاحتفالات والمناسبات التي يحتفل
فيها الفلسطينيون وبتحديد في الاعياد عيد
الميلاد المجيد في مدينه بيت لحم شكرا
جزيلا لك سمير ابو شنب من ساحه كنيسه
المهد في بيت لحم
[موسيقى]
تشهد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عاصفه
ثلجيه توصف بالتاريخيه حيث افادت مراسله
الجزيره في واشنطن عن 19 شخصا
ومسرعهم في انخفاض قياسي لدرجات الحراره
في مابات الملايين بلا كهرباء ابرز نتائج
ما خلفته العاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب مناطق
الولايات المتحده نتبعه في العرض الثالث
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من واشنط مراسل الجزيره ناصر
الحسين ناصر ما المختلف في هذه العاصفه
الثلجيه التي توصف بانها تاريخي
المختلفه
الولايات المتحده حتى الان هو درجه
الحراره
القطبيه ان صح التعبير منذ 48 ساعه الان
رياح قويه من الشمال من كندا ريح قطبيه
هاجمت مدن مثل ديترويت شيكاغو دينغر
وبلغت درجه الرياح
في الساعه
والدار نزل درجه الحراره بشكل فجاه
الامريكيين ولم يتمكنوا حققتهم
والحقيقه ان الرياح القطبيه بشكل سريع
اينما حللت تنزل درجه الحراره الى الثقيل
وبالتالي درجه
الحراره الاوس
ط عبره والشتاء شيكاغو
اللي ناحيه الصفر الان تحت 20 تحت 40 في
بعض الحالات ما جاء على السلطات تطلب الان
من السكان البقاء او المكوثه في منازلهم
وفي كثير من الولايات السلطات المحليه
منعت تماما السائقين من قياده
حفاظا على حياتهم وموجه الصقيع هذه وصلت
ايضا الى مناطق لم تصل لها من قبل مثل همم
مش سلبي مثل تاكسي كلها في الجنوب ولايه
ساخنه لكنها الان تعيش بردا قاسيا تحت
الصفر الان الاهم من هذا او الجانب الاخر
في هذه العاصفه هو الثلوج المدفوعه بقوه
الرياح هذه الثلوج مدفوعه بقوه الرياح
الان تقصف منطقه بافلو شمال غرب نيويورك
وهناك التركيز والاهم حيث اعلنت حاكمه
الولايه قبل ساعات فقط حاله الطوارئ في
تركيا
ما زالوا عالقين ولم تتمكن السلطات من
الوصول اليهم بسبب انعدام الرؤيه قوه
الرياح وقوه الثلوج التي تاتي بها تلك
الرياح وبالتالي حاله شفه مستحيله للوصول
واهتمام عملي وبالتالي تحاول السلطه هناك
الامكان ان تصل الى هؤلاء لاعاده الى
منازل ومناطق دافئه ثم لدينا الالاف همم
من المواطنين الان في معظم كبريات الاكبر
المطارات في دنفر في مطار اتلانتا في مطار
شيكاغو في مطار بافلو المغلق الان كلهم
عالقون وهناك فوضع عامه في ارخص حجوزات
السفر
والكل عالق هناك الكل يريد ان يصل الى
وجهته خاصه في ليله عيد راس عيد عيد
الميلاد وبالتالي حاله صعبه يعيشها
الامريكي ولكن اصعب ايضا تلك الارقام عن
اعداد الضحايا والقتله التي بدات تصل
تباعا حول 20 قتينا الان على مختلف طرق
ولايات السلفانيا
كانوا يقودون سياراتهم ويبدوا انهم فوجئوا
بالعاصفه الثلجيه والعاصفه القطبيه وحصل
كثير من حوادث السير ذهب ضحيتها ما لا يقل
عن 19 الى 20 مواطن الامريكيه في الساعات
القليله الماضيه الان يتوقع ان يتحسن هذا
الطقس خلال 48 ساعه امامنا يومين او يومين
همم تواجه الولايات المتحده هذا الصقيع
الذي لم تشرح لم تشهدوا الولايات المتحده
حتى المناطق البارده الشمالا لم تشهده منذ
40 عام كندا ايضا تواجه نفس المشكله
والناس في داخل بيوتهم وموجه من الصقيع
والرياح القويه التي تدفع بالثلوج
والامطار الجليديه ما يفرض على كندا
والولايات المتحده علاقه في المناطق
المضروبه ان ان تشل الحركه عمليا فيه شكرا
جزيلا لك ناصر الحسيني من واشنطن
كان هذا عن الاوضاع في الولايات المتحده
اما احوال اللاجئين والنازحين السوريين في
قصه اخرى سنويها بعد قليل في فقره
المتابعه
قال اللواء الليبي المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ان
قوته ستمنح فرصه اخيره الى الاطراف التي
وصفها بالمتصارعه لوضع خريطه طريق تنتهي
باجراء الانتخابات وطالب حفتر في كلمه له
امام حشد من انصاره في بنغازي بعثه الامم
المتحده بتحمل مسؤوليتها واتخاذ الخطوات
اللازمه لحل الازمه الليبيه
الخارجي جزء من مشاكل ليبيا
ان القياده العامه للجيش الوطني الليبيه
تمنح الاطراف المتسارعه الفرصه الاخيره
[موسيقى]
في نهايه المطاف الى تحديد موعد الحقيقه
لاجراء الانتخابات العامه
[موسيقى]
الليبيه من خلال التوافق على حل مبني على
توافق وطني وتجنب اي اعمال تصاعديه من
شانها ان تهدد وحده واستقرار ليبيا اللذين
وصفهما بالهاشين اصلا
وطلب باتري في بيان بمناسبه الذكرى
الحاديه والسبعين لاستقلال ليبيا القاده
الليبيين بوضع نهايه
للمراحل الانتقاليه وتحضير البلاد لاجراء
الانتخابات واكد ان الامم المتحده لن تدخر
جهدا في العمل مع جميع الاطراف بشكل شامل
وبناء وحازم وذلك لدعم الفرقاء الليبيين
تي دون تعميق الانقسامات واهدار المزيد من
الوقت على حد تعبيره
قالت السفاره الامريكيه في ليبيا ان اجراء
انتخابات الرئاسيه وبرلمانيه حره ونزيهه
في اقرب وقت ممكن يظلوا المطلب الواضحه
للشعب الليبي وداعت السفاره في بيان لجهات
للجهات الفاعله الى العمل مع الممثل الخاص
للامين العام للامم المتحده للاتفاق بسرعه
على قاعده دستوريه
وقالت انه اذا لم يتم التوصل لاتفاق سريع
بشان خارطه طريق انتخابيه النزيهه فيمكن
بل ينبغي استخدام اليات بديله لاعتماد
قاعده دستوريه للانتخابات واكدت التزام
الولايات المتحده بدعم الحوار الليبي
الشامل تحت رعايه الامم المتحده
شهدت عده مناطق في الولايات الشماليه بل
في الولايه الشماليه في السودان هجره
جماعيه لغياب الخدمات الاساسيه وبحثا عن
فرص افضل للحياه
وبين ما خلت قرن كامله من سكانها وصلت
نسبه الهجره الى مناط في مناطق اخرى الى
80% من السكان
وتوجه من هجره مسقط راسهم صوب العاصمه
الخرطوم والى عده دول من
العالميه لهذه الهجره على المولود الثقافي
والحضاري
بعد 45 عاما
عدى عباس الى قريته هنا في جزيره ديفيل
فقيره وشبه المهجوره وسط نهر النيل
بالولايات الشماليه على بعد نحو 700 كيلو
متر عن العاصمه الخرطوم
هاجر في منتصف السبعينيات بحثا عن حياه
افضل
وهذه اول عوده الى القريه من ابناء جيلي
اكثر من 1200 شخص هاجروا بحثا عن عمل
وتعليم للابناء ورعايه الصحيه لم يبقى في
جزيره دجله سوى بضعه اشخاص
الجزيره
مهجوره من اهلها لنفس اسباب البحث عن
مقاومه الحياه مع ان هذه الربوعه جاره
لنهر النيل
هذه الديار تسكنها اليوم ذكريات وحنين
تمسكت الحاج طيبه بالبقاء في قريتها هي
وبعض كبار السن كانت الحياه تمرض يوما
وتعج بالسكر
واليوم قد لا يجدوا من بقي جارا يلقي عليه
السلام
لكنهم هجروها بحثا عن التعليم والعمل
وهاجروا الى الخرطوم وخارج السودان الان
في كل الاتجاهات لا تجد احدا نتمنى ان
يعود الى ديارهم
بلد البنجر
[موسيقى]
غاده هذه القريه ومناطق اخرى مهجوره تحتفظ
بذكرى اهلها وهم يحتفظون بذكرياتهم في
ربوعها لعل اشواقهم تعيد بوصله هجرتهم
يوما ما نحو الشمال مره اخرى الطاهر
المرضي الجزيره من الولايه الشماليه
العواصف الثلجيه في الولايات المتحده
ومعنا من نيويورك عامر سعد الخبير في
سياسات المناخ ومدير مؤسسه
[موسيقى]
لاستشارات المناخ اهلا وسهلا بك نريد ان
نعرف ما الذي تعنيها هذه العاصفه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده ماذا يمكن ان تكون
تاثيراتها
هذه هي العاصفه كانت مدمره حقنا لحد الان
نرى الان درجات الحراره منخفضه قياسيه في
عبر البلاد وراينا اكثر من 12 حاله وفاه
الولايات المتحده وانا موجود هنا في
نيويورك حيث ان درجه الحراره تقل عن 10
بال 10 ايضا نيويورك
بشكل كبير الكثير من المنازل
البيوت الفقراء لا يحصلون على تدفئه
مناسبه وكانتيجه لنتوقع ربما رؤيه ارتفاع
نتيجه درجات الحراره المتجمده
اعتقد اننا عرفنا ان العاصفه كانت في
طريقها خلال الايام القليله الماضيه وحتى
رغم ذلك لم نقوم بالتهيئه بشكل كافي خلال
العاصفه اكثر من 2000 رحله 2000 رحله تم
الغائها عبر البلاد والكثير من الاشخاص
الذين كانوا يرغبون بالعوده الى منازلهم
عالقوا في المطارات وفرض عليهم ان يقوموا
بخطط بديله وما رايناه انه هنالك
فساد عيد ميلاد لاعياد الميلاد
والاحتفالات هذه العام
هل كان يمكن تفادي الاسوء هل كانت هناك
امور كان يمكن لي سلطات ان تقوم بها
لتتفادى النتائج الاسود
الواقع هو اننا نعرف ان هنالك ازمه مناخيه
تنتج علامه مثل هذه العواصف راينا قبل
سنوات في تكساس لانه كان هنالك درجات
حراره
متجمده شلت نظام الطاقه الكثير من الاشخاص
توفوا ونظام الطاقه اصابه الفوضى لمده شيء
يحصل الان عبر البلاد حيث انه هنالك طلب
عال على الطاقه من اجل تدفئه المنازل رغم
ذلك لم نجد من امكانياتنا في الطاقه ولم
نقوم بالتهيئه بشكل كافي لالواقع ان همم
ازمه المنام سندها في انحاء البلاد ينتج
عنه زياده في الطلب على الطاقه وزياده في
التكرار هذه العواصف الكبيره والقاسيه
بتغيرات المناخيه الخاصه بالاحتباس
الحراري
عندما تتحدث عن التغيرات المناخيه ما انا
عارفه ان درجات الحراره
المنخفضه وهذه العواصف قد تحدث بشكل متكرر
اكبر مثلا بدايه هذا العام راينا في الشرق
الاوسط كان هنالك درجات حراره مرتفعه تصل
الى 50 او 45 في النهار وفي الليل لم تنخذ
درجات
على انه الاحتباس الحراري عندما
نقوم بالتحدث عن الاحتباس الحراري ارتفاع
في درجات الحراره بشكل عالمي وايضا هنالك
نوع من التطرف في زياده الحراره او
انخفاضه بمعنى ان مثلا هذه العواصف التي
نراها في الولايات المتحده ستخافض درجات
حرارتها بشكل اكبر في الولايات المتحده
وفي اماكن اخرى وايضا نرى التاثيرات
المدمره للازمه المنا المزيد من الفيضانات
ومن الاعاصير وكل من هذه الاحداث ستزدادوا
شدتها وسيزداد ضررها على البني التحتيه
وعلى المنازل وعلى الطرق وايضا تزيد في
مساله الخسائر البشريه التي تحدثها ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك نيويورك سعد عامر الخبير في
سياسات المناخ
نعود الى شمال سوريا حيث تشتد قسوه احوال
الطقس وتتقلص درجات الحراره بشده فتبرز
معاناه اللاجئين والنازحين حتى وصل الامر
بالمفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين الى التحذير من ان الشتاء الحالي
سيكون اصعب من ما كان عليه الامر في
السنوات الاخيره بالنسبه للنازحين قصرا
فكم عددهم وما هي مواقع وجودهم تقدر
المفوضيه عدد اللاجئين والنازحين السوريين
بنحو الثلاثه عشر مليون شخص بينهم همم
خمسه ملايين و700,000 لاجئ وسته ملايين
و700,000 اكثر من 90% منهم ضمن دائره
الفقر يتوزع معظم اللاجئين السوريين على
دول الجوار تركيا نحو ثلاثه ملايين وست ست
مئه الف لاجئ وهي ارقام تشمل اللاجئين
المسجلين في المفوضيه الساميه للاجئين فقط
اما لبنان
يستضيف نحو
825 الف لاجئ مسجلين رسميا في حين
يستضيفوا الاردن نحو 670 الف لاجئا ويقدر
عدد اللاجئين في العراق بنحو 200
163,000 بينما يوجد في مصر نحو 144000
ماذا عن النازحين داخل سوريا عددهم في
شمال غرب البلاد يقدر منهم اليونين
و800,000 شخص يوجد مليون و700,000 منهم في
نحو 1400 الموقع وتشكل النساء والاطفال
ثمانيه في المئه منهم ونحو 46,000 شخص
لديهم احتياجات خاصه
ماذا عن احتياجات اللاجئين والنازحين
الانسانيه يبدو انه لن يكون امام العائلات
سوى الاختيار بين الطعام والتدفئه كما
تقول المفوضيه الامميه في لبنان مثلا يعيش
تسعه من كل عشره لاجئين السوريين في حاله
من الفقر المدقع وهو ما يضطرهم الى الحد
من استهلاك الغذاء وتعليق طلب الحصول على
الرعايه الطبيه بينما يغرق كثير منهم في
الديون
تتزايد هذه الاحتياجات داخل سوريا 14
مليون و600 الف شخص بحاجه لمساعده بمن
فيهم سكان المنطقه نفسها كما ان هناك نحو
سته ملايين شخص بحاجه الامن يستظلون به
ويغفر لهم حدا ادى من متطلبات السكن
اللائق وفي ادلب على سبيل المثال يتضر
النازحون الى ترقيع الخيام
وجمعي الاخشاب والبلاستيك بهدف التدفئه في
وقت وصل فيه سعر طن الحطب الى 200 دولار
من المشاكل الاخرى نقص الاغطيه والخيام
وهو ما يعني تفشل الامراض بين النازحين
غير القادرين اصلا على توفير العلاج
المناسب وهو يعني زياده الوفيات تلك
الظروف
المؤلمه دفعت المفوضيه الامميه الى اطلاق
حمله عالميه لجمع التبرعات في فصل الشتاء
فهي تعاني كما تقول عجزا في التمويل ولذلك
الى تقليص البرامج الاساسيه في بلدان
الحديث عن هذا الموضوع معنا من الجنيف همم
المتحدث باسم المفوضيه المفوضيه الامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين اهلا بك سيد يوكو
هذا يتكرر كل سنه ويعاني اللاجئون
السوريون من هذه الظروف كل سنه لماذا
مساء الخير بدايه شكرا على الاستضافه
للتحدث عن هذا الموضوع المهم هو كما رايتم
فانا السوريين الذين نجحوا الى بلد جوار
يحتاجون الى دعمنا بشكل كبير المفوضيه
العليا للاجئين تقوم بتقديم المساهمه
مساعده نحن نوفر الملابس الشتويه
والبطانيه
وايضا
معدات حمايه ونقدم
المبالغ النقديه
اماكنهم وبيوتهم لكن كما تعرف ان الازمه
في سوريا استمرت الان لحوالي 12 عاما وهذه
المعاناه تستمر معها والشتاء
يزيد من الاحتياجات الناس الذين هم في
ظروفنا صعبه للغايه في المنطقه
نعم ولكن يبدو بشكل واضح ان هذه المساعدات
لا تكفي وهناك معاناه كبيره جدا وكما قلت
تتكرر كل سنه يعني منذ 11 عاما او يزيد
فما الذي يمكن فعله لحمايه هؤلاء مما
يعانون من البرد وهذه اسر واطفال وامور
مؤلمه للغايه
قد استمرت لسنوات عديده ولسوء الحظ فانا
فصل الشتاء يحمل معه الكثير من الصعوبات
درجات الحراره تحت الصفر ونحن اا
نحاول ان نساعده الاكثر احتياجا كل من
يحتاج مساعدتنا الوضع الصعب للغايه عائلات
يتوجب عليها ان همم تتنازل عن بعض الوجبات
من اجل ان تدفئه اطفالها والناس ايضا
يحاولون همم
العنايه الصحيه والرعايه الصحيه بالتالي
انا اكمل الوقت الذي والفرصه التي تحتمها
للتحدث الى الناس الكثير من الاشخاص
انتبهوا الى الان ينتبهون الى ازمه مختلفه
في العالم لكن لسوء الحظ فان الوضع داخل
سوريا وفي دولي جوالها يستمر بكونه صعب
الدولي لا يهتم
لان الرساله التي تودين ان تقوليها وتقول
لها على شاشهنا يعلمها المجتمع الدولي ولا
شك
ان المجتمع الدولي على علم لكن لدينا
صعوبات وسيناريوهات مختلفه متضاربه تحدث
مثلا في لبنان قد ارتفعت نسبه تكلفه
المعيشه الى 700 بالمئه في داخل سوريا
شكرا جزيلا لك من جنيف ايووكو ناروشيما
المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين
[موسيقى]
لن نبتعد عن الم الناجحين واللاجئين
السوريين يا امي دفينا ايدينا بالحاح يعنس
الصغار بهذه العباره في اذان امهات
يعتصرهن الالم لانه لا حول لهن ولا قوه ان
يتالم الرجال والنساء من قوه ظروفهم بما
فيها ظروف المناخيه السيئه حاليا لكن
صرخات الاطفال
فماذا حدث لضمير الانسانيه هل ما زال
بعضنا يالم ببعض الحق
تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]